hello we're talking about distribution
the new worlds a whole new world of
distribution we just watched our movie
here at the DGA kind of a screening for
distributors to try to get distributors
that's come out interested in the movie
um and you know there are a lot of
questions about distribution and a lot
of people it's a whole new world and we
recently did this xbox deal through we
put a Slamdance Film Festival and
through Slamdance for one week during
the festival on your xbox 360 if you own
an xbox you could watch our movie the
scenesters along with three other
Slamdance titles it was kind of a slam
dance in your living room and Sundance
did a tie-in with YouTube where they did
the same thing and South by Southwest
did it tie in with on-demand i use Time
Warner on demand and I believe that the
South by Southwest deal is it's not just
for a week it's on lock it's on your
cable now so you can go to the festival
in Austin and see these movies and then
now you can just go home and buy them on
your on demand and for us you know for
one week we played and I thought it was
great you know if you're a kid in
Wisconsin where else are you able to see
new independent films of distribution
and the weight distribution is going is
I think it's a it's from the ground up
it's from fans and people demanding the
to see a movie paranoia activity would
be a good example of people wanted to
see that movie and the distributors
caved in and they sent it to your city
so with these online deals whether it's
through xbox or youtube or on demand if
you get people watching your movie and
interested in it they're going to tell
their friends hey hey this movie is
great you should see it
so i think it's a it's a grassroots
distribution effort and you know we got
a lot of good press out of the Xbox deal
and a lot of people saw it and you know
it's not on anymore but we were able to
take stories of people who saw it on the
Xbox and take kind of our numbers and
everything to then go to distributors
and say hey look this many people
watched it not knowing anything about it
other than the description and they were
really interested so we're just
finalizing kind of our distribution
stuff now after this DJ screening and I
don't know I'm a big fan and the
festival's is just another way to
getting press to get press for your
movies one of the great things you can
do because a good review of your movie
from a respectable respect respectable
newspaper or magazine is worth its
weight in gold because you can hand out
all the fliers you want and you can hand
out all the posters you want but an
actual film critic reviewing your movie
is the best press you will ever get so
to play festivals is not just exposure
and they're not just fun to fly to and
go drink at but you get the local
community invested it goes online and
it's a good way to just again get
support
Oh